in this video we'll quickly talk about
how training would work in a more
general conditional random field setup
we've mentioned in previous videos that
we do not need to restrict ourselves to
linear chain conditional random fields
if we were modeling a pixel labeling
problem we could use a grid structure
where each node would correspond to one
of the pixels in the image and we'd have
factors that would express preferences
on the joint value of neighboring pixels
in the image or we could have a very
complicated structure over a graph where
we have several types of loops and we
can even have factors that will involve
more than just two variables I could
even have a structure that varies for
different pairs of training inputs and
targets so I'm mentioning an example
where we have webpages that and we're
modeling the label between webpages that
share a link and if we have different
groups of webpages then the different
groups of webpages might have different
will of course have different network
structures or from modeling the web
pages from the pages of one on one
University website versus another
University of websites of course these
would be different pages and they'll be
connected differently so the conditional
random field framework is very general
for modeling the interaction between
random variables so concepts that we're
trying to model now what about training
such general conditional random fields
well to do that we still perform
gradient descents so for a given pair of
target and input we would need to derive
what is the expression for the partial
derivative of the negative log
likelihood of observing some given
target given some input with respect to
any parameter theta in our model and it
also it actually takes a failed
simple expression that's very general so
that's partial data it will always be
minus the sum over all the factors of
the partial derivative with respect to
my parameter of interest of the log
factors so over all the factors I'm
taking the sum of the partial live of
the each log factor with respect to my
parameter and I'm subtracting to that
the expectation over the what could be
the true label why I did this is the
expectation with respect to the model
again the sum of the partial derivative
of the log factors so here we have a
difference between what a grain of what
is based on what is observed minus the
gradient based on what the modeled
thinks its conditioned on the input but
we're doing an expectation over what the
model thinks is most likely and if you
think about this expression what it's
trying to do is that it's trying to make
the log factor larger for the values of
Y that are in the training set and an
expectation is trying to make the log
factor smaller an expectation for
essentially every value of y based on
what the model currently thinks the way
the signs probability to other values of
Y so if the model becomes very good then
P of Y given X T is going to be peaked
you can assign a very high probability
to the true target Y T and then 0 to
everything else in which case these two
terms will cancel out and otherwise
training would proceed until we have
converged to a conditional distribution
that's very close to assigns
essentially perfect probability to D the
true answer now in this expression the
main problem is computing the
expectation over Y here so this
expectation here of this whole
expression so for one thing and it's an
expectation over all values for all the
elements in the Y vector
but usually since each of the log
factors will only involved maybe a pair
or triplet or just a subset of the Y's
then usually this expectation reduces to
an expectation over just a subset of the
variables so you know use for instance
in the linear chain conditional random
field we saw that essentially these
expectations were only over either a
single Y key variable or pair Y key
variable so often it's only going to
involve a few of these Y key variables
that being said computing the
conditional distribution over these
subsets of Y variables if the graph is
not a tree or a chain that's still
intractable we have to approximate that
conditional distribution and what we can
use is the loopy variant of belief
propagation to approximate that
conditional distribution so it's just a
reminder of how we can use the log
messages as computed by belief
propagation so we're running a belief
propagation usually in log space we run
it where we iterate over all the
messages that are being passed between
factors and variables and vice versa and
we go over these messages several times
until the value of the messages doesn't
change and once this has converged then
we can compute for instance the marginal
probability over just a single Y given X
as just the exponential of the log
factor that only involves YK plus the
sum for all the other factors of the log
messages that comes from them so this
way we have a way of approximating in
this case the marginal distribution but
we can generalize this formula to any
subset of Y k's so I won't go more into
the details of this
this just give you a head start if you
want to go look at the literature for
how to perform and train general
conditional random field models using
loopy belief propagation